Greg uh why is it that you never see
antifa in a small town of what Jason's
saying if what Jason is saying is so
racist I don't know I mean I think it
has a lot to do with density it's easier
to hide in cities I think you know um
this is a really interesting flip if you
look at a the our first block of the
second block
it's the left it's the Liberals that are
coming out after either speech or art
and it's the right that is defending it
yeah this is a complete flip of the
whole freedom of speech movement of the
1970s only in this current race-baiting
media culture can an anti-crime message
also be seen as anti-black
why does your brain say black when you
see crime and I'm not asking the people
at home I'm asking the media right there
was no race imagery in that video there
was no lynching imagery in that video
but the Liberals and the media they see
black people in this they feel black
people in this it's because the media
has said it is it is racist to condemn a
violence they are the ones doing the
conflation by excusing violence in the
name of social justice we've now gone to
the next natural step anti-violence now
means anti-black apparently if you if
you are disgusted by looting or mob
violence or Smash and grabs and it
sickens you and you think the second
amendment protects you from that you are
a white supremacist you see what
happened there who's saying this it's
the media this is why I don't even fault
people
who say this video was racist because
that's not their opinion right it's not
their opinion it's been drilled into
them it's an opinion that has been put
into your heads it's shaping their
narratives it's not their own the same
people that are calling out this thing
that this was a this was a location for
a lynching do you think that was their
original opinion do you think that every
person that's been on TV goes oh my God
I recognize that place it's from 100
years ago I said no no no no no no no
nobody in the media has an original
opinion about anything it comes from
somewhere else so take yourself
righteousness shove it up your ass
nobody believed nobody had that point
out it ain't aldeed's fault that he
didn't know they made a movie that
wasn't their fault did that movie star
star Miley Cyrus Hannah Montana Hannah
Montana that's a worse thing Hannah
Montana should not be in movies you know
I'm just joking I'm just joking but but
the thing is now it's down to the
location yeah so they're they're drilled
they're they're narrowing it down to
like well now it's their location I
think if they knew maybe they might have
thought about but I don't think they
knew the meaning just the media has
created this environment where now if
you actually think that this behavior is
wrong they're the ones linking the
behavior to race not you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else